il aura fallu attendre trente trois ans
pour voir une française prendre place
enfin dans un vaisseau spatial 17 août
1996 claudie haigneré devient la
première femme française à s'envoler
vers l'espace un aboutissement après
plusieurs mois d'une intense préparation
physique et théorique
en 1985 elle est la seule femme parmi
six hommes à être sélectionné pour
participer à un programme spatial
de quoi attiser la curiosité des
journalistes questions parfois un peu
hasardeuses comme vous étiez petit vous
lisiez plutôt bécassine ou plutôt tintin
on a marché sur la lune
dans ce milieu d'hommes de militaires et
pilote d'essai comment juge-t-on la
présence féminine une question bête vous
m'excusez mais le fait d'être une femme
ça apporte quelque chose où vous après
juste sur votre curriculum vitae sur vos
diplômes et votre compétence
face à ces journalistes maladroit
claudie haigneré affichant calme
olympien
sûre d'elle et de sa légitimité à faire
ce voyage spatial a accepté dans ce
milieu professionnel effectivement il y
avait davantage d'hommes que de femmes
en fonction de mes compétences propres
et puis ensuite on a apprécié par la
qualité du travail que j'ai pu fournir
au cours des entraînements et je crois
je n'ai pas ressenti à aucun moment
avoir quelque chose à prouver en plus en
participant à cette mission les
spationautes espérait aussi envoyer un
message à toutes les femmes
je suis très heureuse de pouvoir en tant
que femmes et plus de montrer aux fans
qu'on peut aller au bout d'un objectif
mais ça peut paraître ambitieux et un
peu difficile parce que c'est un milieu
masculin dans lequel on évolue
moi c'est une mission que je que je me
fixe claudie haigneré fera de voyage
dans l'espace
celui de 1996 à bord de la station mir
et l'autre à bord de la station spatiale
internationale en 2001 depuis elle
partage son expérience auprès de jeunes
et déplorent toujours le manque de
femmes candidates à la conquête de
l'espace
jeunes filles n'ont pas suffisamment
confiance en elle pour aborder ces
métiers pour entrer pour s'orienter vers
ces carrières et là il ya un problème
qui est lié probablement une
représentation des métiers des clichés
avaient serré au type à une forme
d'éducation donc il faut leur donner
confiance et leur expliquer ce que sont
ces métiers en 2019 claudie haigneré est
toujours la seule femme parmi les dix
spationaute français à s'être rendu dans
l'espace
[Musique]